chas the sequel is here where
jason rants our longtime chaz
correspondent seattle radio show host
joins us now with details hey jason
hey summer of love in seattle to i guess
the winter of discontent in portland
north portland specifically it's the red
house
autonomous zone a group of activists
within the antifa movement
have set up basically a two two and a
half block radius around a house that
was lost to foreclosure after a two year
battle
the family is black and indigenous and
so the primarily white antifa residents
believe that this is an example
of gentrification there's no actual
evidence that this is gentrification
however there is a lot of evidence that
there's been a lot of crime going on as
the
folks refused to leave cops yesterday
tried to remove them from the home
finally removed them from the home
except they came under assault the
officers from
a lot of people who set up camp there as
they were treated it ended up giving
a lot of room to the antiva protesters
to set up a camp
and right now they are barricaded
they've got a stockpile of weapons
they've got armed guards they've got
a kitchen ready so they're there for the
long haul
as the portland police department are
trying to figure out what exactly
they're going to do but they
are amplifying the urgency of the
messaging saying
you guys do have to leave peacefully
we're not going to put up with this so
we could potentially see action from the
police in the next 24 hours
it's happening because we are putting up
with it you get what you put up with if
you let your kids smoke weed at the
breakfast table they will
that's the lesson jason rants great to
see you